maintien d'ordre comment assurer ce
maintien de l'ordre dans les
manifestations ultra violente c'est le
défi qui est posé chaque samedi au gilet
au faso gilet jaune
la question qui est soulevée aujourd'hui
c'est celle de l'utilisation des
lanceurs de balles de défense par les
forces de l'ordre alors c'est l bd comme
on dit ce sont finalement les versions
modernes des flashball elle aurait
provoqué ça ce sont des sources
policières six cas d'infirmité
permanente des personnes qui ont été
soit éborgné soit comme une main
arrachée une vingtaine disent même des
sources proches des manifestants en tout
cas le défenseur des droits jacques
toubon demande qu'on suspende
l'utilisation de ces armes
intermédiaires il était ce matin
l'invité de rtl on les écoute
nous avons déterminé à partir des cas
qui nous sont soumis que effectivement
lusage des flashball usage des lanceurs
de balles de défense 40 46 pouvait
présenter une grande dangerosité
nous avons demandé nous avons demandé le
moratoire nous avons demandé que soit
tout ça soit régulier gelé encore fait
dans un rapport déposé il y a un an
auprès du président de l'assemblée
nationale sans effet sur la doctrine du
médiator et je dis simplement que
j'espère que devant l'évidence
aujourd'hui de ce que nous avons dit la
dangerosité de ces armes de fouace
intermédiaire le gouvernement prendra
des dispositions raison c'est un arsenal
trop dangereux alors d'abord je dois
faire une remarque qui va dans le sens
de ce qu'on vient de dire jacques toubon
dit ça et cet après midi j'ai pas soudés
sur les réseaux sociaux rentrer dans la
polémique
son traitement son salaire c'est à dire
que tous les débats déborde les uns sur
les autres et ça c'est la nouvelle a été
posée dès ce matin d'ailleurs absolument
une nouvelle à je me laisserai donc
traite nouvel âge médiatique et où
vraiment on a vu que benalla déborde ce
grand débat national que la halle à
faire d'eux des blessés dans les chalets
gilet jaune déborde sur le grand débat
national aussi et maintenant voilà que
jacques toubon est au milieu de l'eau
donc c'est vraiment c'est-à-dire
intéressant parce que vous allez voir
que ça ça désessard des effets c'est à
dire sans trop longtemps comme ça on se
pose la question savoir son traitement
sans salaire c'est un rallye ça fait
trente mille euros à la croix de mémoire
pasquet commence par sa chance car sur
des droits est différente retraite oui
mais la peau de son est vrai en saxe et
plus ils cumulent des retraites est un
traitement important
il ya des règles dans la fonction
publique vous pouvez pas cumuler une
retraite de la fonction publique ou a
fortiori plusieurs et un traitement de
je ne sais plus quoi je crois qu'à celle
de 14000 euros par mois donc je ne sais
pas moi j'aimerais bien en tout cas qui
est une explication parce que ça ça va
encore alimenter des balises évidemment
et ça et ça alors maintenant sur le fond
du problème ces armes alors moi je suis
toujours un peu gêné par en tant que
spécialiste quand même de politologie
c'est que je rappelle quand même coeur
matière de violence système ce qui
définit l'état d'après mark webber
l'état en a le monopole c'est à dire que
peut pas reprocher à un policier
d'utiliser des moyens violents puisqu'il
a il est justement chargé de garantir la
sécurité de l'état maintenant j'y
rajoute tout de suite il y a eu
visiblement et notamment il ya une
enquête intéressante de france info qui
vient d'être faite il ya une quarantaine
de blessés sérieux un parent c'est par
ces instruments alors il semble que tout
ça en fait soit la conséquence c'est moi
je n'accuse surtout pas les forces de
l'ordre surtout d'une impréparation
c'est à dire qu'on s'aperçoit que ce que
tous les cas je dis bien tous les cas
qui ont été signalés sont des cas qui
concerne la police et non pas la
gendarmerie alors que la gendarmerie a
été la plus impliquée dans les dents
dans le maintien de l'ordre et que et
notamment des gens des policiers qui ne
sont pas du tout habitués qui viennent
qui viennent de secteurs qui ne sont pas
habitués à ce genre de faire
effectivement ce que j'entendais un
syndicaliste de la police syndicat en
question mais qui disait on à un prêt de
formation avec ses armes
et là vous avez vu que le directeur de
la police nationale a envoyé une lettre
au taquet pour justement rappelé les
contenus contre les conditions d'emploi
de ce genre d'armes qui peuvent en effet
être est catastrophique heureusement que
vous avez certainement une idée sur la
question
moi je pense que ce pouvoir de façon
générale et expose la police et on l'a
vu dans la sphère benalla ce qui a quand
même provoqué la démission du ministre
de l'intérieur c'est pas rien c'est à
dire qu'on a compris qu'en fait c'était
lié qui ne voulaient pas s'engager donc
ce qu'ils disent d'ailleurs juste pour
finir assumer ce qui rajoute comme une
info non mais bon qu'est mais de façon
générale il est très clair pour
quiconque a été dans les manifestations
du gilet jaune et je pense que le
journaliste que le figaro envoyé pour
filmer en live a eu des coups de feu des
tirs de flash ball qui l'a reçu à deux
reprises il ya eu des dizaines de
journalistes qui ont été dans cette
situation
il ya eu très clairement une stratégie
d'intimidation de la part du pouvoir par
rapport à cette manif ces manifestations
parce qu'ils ne savaient pas quoi faire
comme ils n'avaient pas d'interlocuteur
il était débordé par ses ressortent de
mobilisation qui venait de nulle part il
ya une forme de panique contrôle et qui
a impliqué que très rapidement les
manifestations ont eu l'objectif du
pouvoir n'a pas été de laisser les
manifestations se déroulaient dans
l'ordre mais au contraire d'essayer dé
disperser le plus vite possible ce qui a
d'ailleurs entraîné une recrudescence
des violences
au fil des actes auprès des gilets
jaunes parce qu'il ya des personnes qui
venaient des quatre coins de la france à
paris pour manifester et au bout de dix
minutes il était sorti à coups de gaz
lacrymogènes et on se retrouve
évidemment qu'est ce qu'ils faisaient
ils aller ailleurs pour manifester à
lille ne s'y passait pas alors qu'ils
aient fait cet effort et de la même
façon et du coup la police s'est
retrouvé dans un rôle presque politique
c'est-à-dire de défendre les intérêts du
gouvernement qu'il n'avait pas intérêt à
ce que la mobilisation semaine de cette
façon c'est pour ça qu ils ont créé le
grand débat pour essayer de canaliser de
renvoyer les gilet jaune perd quelque
chose de plus contrôler et du coup la
police se retrouve dans une fonction
politique elle n'a pas à voir c'est à
dire qu'elle n'a pas juste elle se
retrouve quelque chose qui dépasse
largement qui du coup l'exposer
directement à la population
et ça c'est grave ça c'est grave et ça
entraîne évidemment des débordements de
tous les côtés et en particulier de
policiers qui sont obligés de venir a
désormais d'abord dû
c'est juste une précision parce que
roanne et 10 ans régis et qu' il n'y a
pas du tout prouvé que les établi que ce
qui est arrivé au journalisme un terme
en figaro live été provoquée du fait
volontairement de la police parce que
sinon j'ai pas évidemment oui pardon
pour le sait ces armes là je pense
qu'effectivement il ya un problème de
formation effet celle ci s'avère ce
qu'on dit que ce sont des équipes moins
informés qu'ils ont utilisé donc je
pense qu'il faut effectivement une
formation très strict sur ce gendarme
qui peuvent être dangereuses après par
rapport aux violences
je crois pas que c était uniquement la
méchante police qui a déclenché des
violences a déjà il ya pourtant que
journaliste ya beaucoup de journalistes
qui ont été agressés par des gels et
jaune très très violemment
donc il ya de la violence dans ce
mouvement qui a été d'abord verbale et
qui ans était devenu physique et massive
moi j'ai suivi en tant que journaliste
beaucoup enfin pas mal de manifestations
épouse encadrait fin plus encadrées par
des syndicats pour nous pour la plupart
de fonctionnaires ou même du 1er mai
j'étais plus sur la place de la bastille
il n'ya jamais problème quand les gens
sont pacifiques
il n'y a pas de problème lehmann devait
mener les manifestants fonctionnaires
qui défilent pacifiquement pour leur
pouvoir d'achat
après ils sont pas entendus c'est une
chose mais il n'y a pas non mais il n'y
a pas de problème le problème n'est pas
ne vient pas de la police n'est pas la
police qui m'a taclé persona dit c'était
la police qui avait l'intention de
nommer une espèce de dialectique riz par
des petits mots et des insinuations
ferait entendre qu'en fait les gens sont
si tu es responsable oui voilà c'est ça
et que je serai super les gens serait
super gentille déjoue tout à fait
pacifique et le poids aux gars qu'ils
auraient fait dérailler et ces jeunes
respect cette fois j'ai mon outil la
gestion de l'ordre social de façon
générale donc un moment si on décide de
se présenter à des fonctions politiques
et d'être élu on assume la
responsabilité du maintien de l'ordre
dans tous les sens mais pas seulement
dans la ces personnes ne sont pas que
c'est la police
non je n'ai jamais dit qu'on comme ça
c'est parce qu ici c'est ce que j'essaie
d'expliquer c'est de pouvoir politique
et lui le responsable d'avions mais je
suis content comme on dit
monopole de la violence appartient au
pouvoir politique c'est comme si ça
c'est normal c'est comme si vous dénie
aux joj les gens toute intention ou non
les gilet jaune ils peuvent être
autonomes du poids politique tout n'est
pas dans la tête de makoun sont encore
un maquereau et le hareng maquereau et
une autonomie de pensée c'est votre si
je pousse votre raisonnement à l'extrême
tout est politique et tous des socios
apolitique et du coup la personne qui
est indépendante de et de se
repositionner prépare à ça et ne pas
avoir des désirs et des intentions et
des actions qu en fonction de ça ce
n'est pas pratique mais pas de criminels
ou juste la jeune amel temps dans une
intention autonome spéciale est petit
mais autonome de maquereau ou alors
c'est solingen un vrai lac naturel qu'on
se pose la question aujourd'hui de
l'utilisation des flash-ball est une
arme spécifique
moi je pense que le maintien de l'ordre
est un métier qui n'est pas le nôtre sur
ce plateau est apparemment effectivement
la france est un des rares pays à
l'utiliser mais c'est aussi une arme qui
est soumise à des règles on doit frapper
pas les parties génitales pas la tête
manifestement ça n'a pas été le cas donc
il est important de répéter parce que je
crois que finalement au delà de
l'utilisation des flashball il ya
effectivement une remise en question du
monopole de la violence légitime à
l'état par un certain nombre de
responsables politiques pas vous
forcément du tout enfin je n'ai pas
entendu en tout cas mais c'est vrai que
dès qu'il ya un blessé dans une
manifestation liée à la c'est
insupportable la police a blessé
quelqu'un
non je pense que la droite s'est énervé
une fois qu'une enquête a eu lieu et
pour s'est rendu compte que la police a
outrepassé ses fonctions en faites pas
dès lors que j'ai ressenti car ici ça
veut dire quoi la violence légitime ça
veut dire que si vous voyez un policier
taper sur quelqu'un c'est a priori
normal sauf si il est démontré que ça
n'est pas la même façon que si vous
voyez vous voyez une personne qui n'est
pas investie de cette puissance de
proportionnalité auquel cas répond si a
priori à norman sauf si vous démontrez
que c'est normal c'est le premier point
est le deuxième point c'est vous avez
parlé de manifestants ultra violent
effectivement j'ai comme moi entendu
probablement parlé de manifestants qui
arrivent avec des cocktails molotov de
l'acide ou qui apparemment si raide et
des grilles et pour se servir des points
mais c'est ce qui est assez violent je
ne dis pas le contraire mais moi je
pense qu'il faut comparer la manière
dont les forces de l'ordre se comporte
ici avec la manière dont ils se
comportent dans les banlieues parce que
dans les banlieues ou dans certaines
manifestations notamment ceux du
trocadéro je sais pas si vous vous
rendez invalides trocadéro au moment je
crois qu'il ya un événement sportif
football est alors la police avait
regardé les manifestants pia monoprix
faire n'importe quoi sans intervenir
c'était la même chose aux invalides sans
intervenir
et il y à mouthe émeutes dans les
banlieues sporadiques donc personne ne
parle parce que c'est évidemment ils ne
veulent pas je crois que le mot d'ordre
a été donné pour ne pas trop en parler
parce qu'ils ont peur de la contagion où
les policiers ne font rien ils ont pu
notamment par exemple pas le droit de
poursuivre des deux jeunes en scooter
depuis zyed et bouna et c'est donc moi
je crois que symboliquement je moi je
trouve normal que la police fasse son
travail de maintien de l'ordre normal
qu'elle soit très contrôlée si elle le
fait de la mauvaise manière
parce que ça c'est aussi respecter
l'institution et assurer sa pérennité
c'est faire en sorte que toutes les les
violences illégitimes soient sanctionnés
mais je constate que est une des raisons
pour lesquelles les gelées gilet jaune
sont aujourd'hui dans la rue c'est
qu'ils se sentent moins bien traités que
les jeunes des banlieues
c'est vraiment un sujet et je vois
encore que effectivement ne sont pas
traités pareil voilà quelques réactions
sur les juan je sais que vous voulez
encore intervenir on d'abord la parole à
nos internautes qui sont nombreux à
répondre
la question que vous posez c'est là
qu'est la police fait-elle trop de
blessés durant les manifestations du
gilet jaune c'est assez partagés
finalement parce que vous êtes 54% à
dire que oui alors politically nous dit
il faudrait garder à vue jugée
emprisonné casseurs professionnels et
non utilisé des armes létales contre des
gens souvent peu agressifs sont pas des
armes létales attention les
les ce dont on parle et sur les armes
qualifié d'intermédiaire monsieur
babineau d'autres pays s'en sortent très
bien sans ces lanceurs de balles donc
oui il faut s'en débarrasser c'est trop
dangereux élan ajoute non il faut bien
avoir des armes
par contre les cowboys qui vise la tête
par derrière faut les stopper ronito de
son côté il me semble que la police est
contrainte de devoir utiliser des
méthodes violentes non létales même si
les accidents se multiplient a
évidemment un problème de procédure et
d'utilisation et enfin nicole si la
belle s'il avait laissé les cortèges se
déplacer comme prévu il y aurait eu
moins de violences quand on croise les
gens de tous côtés c'est normal ce qui
fait allusion notamment aux changements
aussi de méthode
on l'a vu au fur et à mesure dès samedi
avec ce maintien de l'ordre qui étaient
plutôt justement de ne pas aller à
l'affrontement et puis finalement on a
modifié les ordres dispositif pour
permettre aux forces de l'ordre d'être
plus directement au contact
roanne encore un mot sur le sujet je
voulais juste ajouter quelque chose de
très concret mais est-ce qu'apple quand
même un changement dans les cheveux
longs et le viol on a vu un certain
nombre de policiers nous direct
témoigner de façon alors j'irai
peut-être ils sont dans le rouge depuis
ses dires on a vu en voit en face de
nous des gens qui voulaient nous tuer
oui ça c'est un argument qui était
utilisé par le gouvernement dès l'acte
ii on a vu qu'en fait les personnes qui
sont venues n'y a jamais eu de preuve
justement de ces deux secteurs
il ya des scènes insurrectionnel le
lâchage de cet état policier d'un garde
du corps de journalistes et ce qui est
ce qui est important ici je n'avais pas
les mêmes leur ai dit comme il ya déjà
de l'ac par les flics jamais normal en
même temps il ya des journalistes
sérieux se faire lyncher que moi je
voudrais de joindre témoigné ça à tout
ce que tu dis moi si j'avais pas été
reporter de guerre ici j'avais pas je
tombais en courant je mourrai oui
honte et camille saint-saëns d'essai
d'un an ca me sens blessé parmi les
manifestants je pense qu'encore une fois
on en revient à responsabilités
politiques
lorsqu'un mouvement social qui au départ
qu'on a eu à peu près tous d'accord et
parfaitement pacifique et n'a toujours
pas invoquer de volonté de saccager le
pays mais qu'il ya des réclamations a eu
des réclamations très concrètes
auxquelles le politique n'a pas répondu
il faut s'interroger sur la réalité il
ya un autre élément par exemple on a
parlé des danses lanceurs de balles de
défense
il ya des grenades explosives qui ont
fait qu'il ya des gens des jeunes gens
qui ont perdu des mains et je voudrais
être très précis sur la fête quoi les
ont-ils perdu justement parce que c'est
son brassard c'est oui c'est ça mais
pourquoi est ce que c'est pour les
rouges étaient invités sur les services
de garde
quel est le rôle de ces grenades en fait
c'est d'empêcher les manifestants de
renvoyer les gaz lacrymogènes pour parce
qu'ils auraient peur que l'une d'eux
parce qu'elles sont et de ressemble en
fait aux grenades lacrymogènes normal
qu'ils aient peur que ça leur explose
dans la main mais vous voyez c'est quand
même c'est quand même très très très
pernicieux voix est extrêmement
dangereuse c'est à dire qu'on joue un
jeu dans lequel on va intimider le
manifestant pour qu'en fait il ne
rejette pas une pièce de ronald lee
chromogène mais s'il perce la main ou le
pied comme c'est arrivé quand même
plusieurs fois tant pis et donc là par
exemple ça c'est une autre technique la
matière note qu'il faudrait interroger
mais je ricane constituer un peu ça le
débat
moi ce qui m'étonne beaucoup chez tous
ceux qui dénoncent les violences
policières et encore une fois moi je
suis dit il faut regarder cas par cas et
notamment le problème de l' usage de
cette arme
quand même beaucoup de gens qui
soutiennent qu'ils dénoncent les
violences policières favoris sont très
favorables à des pays où les policiers
en effet ne répond pas avec des
flashballs
mais à ham réel et là on ne gêne les
mêmes personnes ne sont pas du tout
gênée au nicaragua et au venezuela les
manifestants tombent par centaines je
dis bien les mêmes personnes et on
connaît tout à fait et non dans ou la
russie de poutine ou en effet on se sent
ça n'a pas beaucoup on se pose moins de
questions sur les violences policières
suis ce que je veux dire
eh bien ça sera le mot de la fin sur
sujet peut-être pas l'une tout à fait le
dernier jeu propose juste qu'on écoute
parce que c'est intéressant le maire de
toulouse jean luc moudenc a fait part
aujourd'hui du fait qu'ils s'étaient
infiltrés et comme il dit lui-même parmi
la manifestation à toulouse récemment
pour voir pour dit il vivra peu comment
les ça se passe et on écoute son
témoignage la leçon que j'ai tiré c'est
que c'est de la pure violence de la pure
violence et puis ce qui m'a choqué c'est
que j'ai vu côte à côte des gens
d'extrême droite des gens d'extrême
gauche
j'avais jamais imaginé qu'ils puissent
être à ce point en communion de pensée
et d'action est une action qui
consistait malheureusement à tirer des
projectiles contre les forces de l'ordre
là tant que c'était une expérience
particulière mais qui m'a permis de
toucher du doigt de la réalité de là
l'idée assez triste et enfin un dernier
mot à nos internautes
roanne qui nous dit je suis policier et
je condamne ce que font mes collègues
sur les manifestants cette arme est très
dangereuse je ne l'utilisent jamais mes
collègues non plus et l'audace sûr qu'il
nous dit je pense qu'au bout d'un moment
lorsqu'on se fait caillasser pendant des
heures c'est légitime de les utiliser
je propose de parler un peu du brésil
alors cette fois face à l'imbroglio
britannique
la france qui prend les devants le
premier ministre en tout cas sonne la
mobilisation il déclenche le plomb
prévue au cas où le 29 mars prochain la
grande bretagne se retirait de l'europe